badlands national park south dakota
244
000 acres split into two dramatic worlds
the rocky badlands themselves
carved out of the ground by wind and
rain
[Music]
beyond them
an ancient sea of grass
home to the icons
of the old west
[Music]
this land has a long and deep connection
to the indigenous peoples of
america
it's the current and traditional land of
the oglala lakota tribe
for 12 000 years people have used these
lands
but prairie dogs have been here even
longer
[Music]
a female black-tailed prairie dog lives
on the grasslands
in a family group
[Music]
known as a coterie
[Music]
in spring
it's time for her to start a family
after mating she maintains her burrow
and collects nesting material
in doing so
she becomes an eco engineer
her constant gardening benefits over a
hundred species
[Music]
in the sprawling sea of grass
the prairie dog town
is an island of life
drawing in species from far and wide
including predators
[Music]
prairie dogs are the perfect snack
for the coyote
[Music]
the female's quest to start a family
could be over
before it started
[Music]
she's completely oblivious to the thread
[Music]
however
the prairie dog has allies
her neighbors are on high alert
each prairie dog town comes with its own
built-in alarm system
it's one of the most complex animal
languages ever decoded
with specific calls for different
threats
the coyote is spotted
and short chirps call him out
he literally has nowhere to hide
with the threat gone they give the
all-clear signal
a jump yep
the key to thriving in the badlands
is looking out for each other
[Music]
you